Um es mal auf den Punkt zu bringen: Der Physik
rennt die Zeit davon!
Das Standardmodell der Teilchenphysik konnte
zwar immer weiter perfektioniert werden; dennoch
treten die Forschungsteams in diesem Bereich
seit Jahren mehr oder weniger auf der Stelle.
Neue spektakuläre Entdeckungen bleiben aus.
Beispielsweise sind die sogenannte “Dunkle
Energie” und “Dunkle Materie” weiterhin
so rätselhaft wie eh und je.
Doch das soll sich jetzt ändern und zwar
mit dem neuen “Faser” Experiment des CERN:
Leichte extrem schwach wechselwirkende Teilchen,
die man bisher vielleicht übersehen hatte,
sollen so nämlich aufgespürt werden.
Lösen wir damit jetzt endlich die zahlreichen
ungelösten Rätsel der Physik?!
Alles zu dem neuen Experiment erfahrt ihr
jetzt bei Clixoom Science & Fiction, herzlich
willkommen!
Dieses Phänomen macht Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler, die sich mit der physikalischen
Grundlagenforschung beschäftigen, wirklich
total verrückt: Die Rede ist von der sogenannten
“Dunklen Materie”, die Licht weder aussendet
noch reflektiert.
Sie ist unsichtbar und noch nie hat sie irgendjemand
direkt gesehen oder nachweisen können.
Doch obwohl sie nicht direkt sichtbar ist,
macht sich Dunkle Materie indirekt eben schon
bemerkbar.
Und zwar durch ihre Schwerkraft, die ganze
Galaxien um sich gruppiert und die auseinanderfliegen
würden, wenn es die Dunkle Materie nicht
gäbe.
Den gängigen Theorien zufolge ist Dunkle
Materie also durch ihre Wirkung als eine Art
Klebstoff dafür verantwortlich, dass wir
überhaupt existieren!
Denn sie hat nach dem Urknall dafür gesorgt,
dass sich normale Materie überhaupt zu Galaxien
und Sternen verdichten konnte.
Mit “Dunkler Materie” in Verbindung gebracht
werden “Dunkle Photonen”.
Gemeint sind damit quasi die Doppelgänger
normaler Lichtteilchen.
Diese “Dunklen Photonen” endlich aufzuspüren
ist der Traum vieler Physiker-Teams.
Und der könnte vielleicht schon bald in Erfüllung
gehen und zwar mit Hilfe eines neuen Experiments.
Die Forschungskommission der Europäischen
Organisation für Kernforschng (CERN) hat
jetzt das Go gegeben.
Konkret sollen mit Hilfe des sogenannten Faser-Experiment
leichte extrem schwach wechselwirkende Teilchen
aufgespürt werden, die der Forschung bisher
durch die Lappen gegangen sind.
“Faser” steht hier übrigens für “Forward
Search Experiment”.
Die Fachleute sind sehr optimistisch so endlich
die heiß ersehnten Neuentdeckungen zu machen,
die die vier Hauptdetektoren des Large Hadron
Collider (LHC) möglicherweise einfach nicht
erkennen können.
Denn es könnte gut möglich sein, dass die
gesuchten Teilchen - wie eben die Dunklen
Photonen - einfach so aus den Detektoren entlang
des LHC entweichen.
Und so eben bislang unentdeckt blieben.
Konkret soll der Faser-Detektor 480 Meter
vom Atlas-Detektor entfernt seinen Platz finden.
Hiermit hatte man am CERN das Higgs-Boson
nachweisen können.
Der Plan des CERN ist clever: Der Faser-Detektor
soll immer dann aktiv sein, wenn das ATLAS-Experiment
läuft.
Denn die Wissenschafts-Team gehen davon aus,
dass die neuen bislang unbekannten Teilchen
dann entstehen, wenn die Protonen-Strahlen
den Interaktionspunkt des Atlas-Instrumentes
passieren.
Die Protonenstrahlen werden dabei durch Magnete
auf eine geschwungene Bahn gelenkt.
Leicht, nur sehr schwach wechselwirkende Teilchen
würden ihre Flugbahn aber in gerader Linie
fortsetzen.
Zudem gehen die Forschungsteams davon aus,
dass die neuen Teilchen nur wenig gestreut
werden.
Der Faser-Detektor könnte sie dann also registrieren.
Das Instrument soll laut Plan einen Durchmesser
von rund einem Meter haben und dabei nur etwa
fünf Meter lang werden.
Im Vergleich zum Atlas-Instrument also ein
echt kompaktes Ding!
Die anderen Experimente des CERN sollen von
dem Bau des Faser-Experiments aber nicht gestört
werden: Das Instrument soll deswegen in der
gerade stattfindenden Wartungspause des LHC
gebaut werden.
Um Kosten zu sparen und den Bau zügig zu
Ende bringen zu können, sollen laut Plan
Ersatzteile verwendet werden.
Diese werden von den Atlas- und LHCb-Experimenten
bereitgestellt.
Schon ab 20121 sollen dann Daten gesammelt
werden - und das zwei Jahre lang.
Und das ist langfristig gesehen auch nur der
Anfang: Ab 2024 soll dann nämlich der größere
Faser 2-Detektor installiert werden.
Dieser könnte die Entdeckung weiterer noch
unbekannter Teilchen möglich machen!
Klar ist jedenfalls, dass der weltgrößte
Teilchenbeschleuniger LHC in Genf die Physik
weit nach vorne gebracht: unter anderem 2012
durch den Nachweis des Higgs-Boson.
Doch seitdem verlief die Suche nach neuen
Teilchen weitestgehend erfolglos.
Das Faser-Experiment ist ein neuer Versuch,
endlich Kandidaten für die äußerst mysteriöse
Dunkle Materie oder aber supersymmetrische
Teilchen aufzuspüren.
Dazu CERN-Mitarbeiter Eckhard Elsen: “Das
FASER-Experiment ist eine gute Möglichkeit,
der Physik außerhalb des Standardmodells
auf die Schliche zu kommen.
Ich freue mich, dass das so effizient umgesetzt
wird.”
Quantenphysik: Die Grundlagen | von Doktor
Whatson - Draufklicken, anschauen und abonnieren.
Bis dann bleibt dran!